[Music]
sorry movie syncopated reading is still
reading even if you put up the letters
in some weird rhythmic order we refuse
to be impressed by your vowel movement
Jesus crisis movie started off with a
poetry quote am I supposed to do now
should I just stop watching am I about
to watch art or something imitating art
uh unprocessed seafood or how I learned
to stop worrying and love the bomb in
south-central while drinking juice in
the hood overly metaphorical meteor is
overly metaphorical meteor for achill
flighty whities also Riggins dressing
room has its own radiator space heater
fan and air conditioning unit diva much
did we end up here
introspective narration or the
unexpected virtue of inner monologues
answering your daughter's Skype wearing
nothing but underwear Livi tries to
defend itself from the inevitable
cinemasins video by putting some quote
that could be interpreted as a critique
of critics luckily for us we're not
critics we're assholes
ads not this lateness nonsense again how
exactly are you late and why would you
even mention it you left as soon as they
paged you when you sat down exactly when
it was your line Plus aren't you the
boss here the subtlety of Keaton's look
to the rafters here went seconds later
the light will fall is one of the things
that make this movie so special
everything about it points to the
tension between the reality and
mysticism of art just fine will then go
on to note that Michael Fassbender is
doing the x-men prequel Jeremy Renner is
doing the Avengers and Robert Downey jr.
is playing Ironman so where's Michael
Keaton in the Batman franchise in this
world it's the weird problem that comes
up when you mix fantasy and reality and
Michael Keaton plays not Michael Keaton
and Edward Norton plays exactly Edward
Norton you're my best friend gala fan
exposition that Club doesn't have half
your talent and he's making a fortune in
that Tin Man get off
now that Keaton has basically played a
version of Birdman in the Marvel
Universe does that make this
meta-commentary better or worse are we
sure this isn't an actual documentary
look at that yeah cool telekinesis and
all but he apparently has powers that
also include completely changing the
writing on the snow from earlier
including making the word the disappear
over a jury that it was tweeted by a
prostate whispers movies casual mention
of a non-existent Twitter account
results in at least four very lame
versions of prostate whispers on Twitter
and me having to lift him up you're
welcome no absolutely no that's why
years ago I said no to Birdman before
it's interesting with this movie which
parallels Michael Keaton's life and some
respects chooses Birdman for as the
movie he didn't do when it was Batman 3
he didn't do in real life what would
saying he didn't do Birdman 3 be too
on-the-nose how do you know Mike
Schreiner we Sheriff Regina wait a
minute
does that mean that you were here
sleeping together or does that mean that
you and he are sleeping with another
woman at the same time I'm not judging
I'm just fantasize
renner great your ass is great dude
series beyond the general ickiness of
the line she's wearing loose cut-offs
does harassment now come with x-ray
vision included also Mike shiner is a
horny or devil than the average
cinemasins writer next thing you know
he's going to be complaining that the
scene doesn't contain a lapdance turner
ups the person who has crucial
information for no reason other than to
advance the plot or embarrass themselves
cliche looks like Mike shiner went to
the Quentin Tarantino school a fake
stuff needs to be real in order to truly
work when performing things if getting
Mike shiner was such a big catch and the
sales are depending on him why is his
name and face nowhere to be found on any
of the ads outside the theater premises
when he invented the circus really cuz
according to a musical I saw recently he
was a kind-hearted and attractive
businessman with a voice of satin and a
heart for the outcasts and that's not
your fault per se but here's a sin for
just making me think of that movie that
didn't exist when this one came out
believe it or not the only opinion that
matters in your theater is hers I
actually don't believe it in all of New
York one voice do the other newspapers
even employee theater critics why would
they if only one voice matters also they
just randomly walked into this bar and
the one person's opinion who matters is
sitting at the bar right now
that's incredible you're breaking
thompson's where does this woman come
from and how does she have such
spectacular eyesight riggan is sitting
with his back to the door because she
has her kid with her we're left to
assume she was on the street spotted him
inside this bar then dragged her family
inside to go pester him that's a
hardcore fan right there man and then
becomes the critic when he can
the harvest I'm kind of surprised
Tabitha didn't say something along the
lines of luckily I'm a woman or
something from the book of the e1 are we
sending this because she doesn't say it
why yes yes we know and what have if she
did see how that works
Mike tries to method Lindsey during her
performance and despite her
unwillingness he persists and it's
hilarious because he has a visible boner
on stage later hold on while I try to
think of a real reason that might be
funny
this blood squib is clearly blowing away
from Lesley and Mike but when we see
them later they are covered in blood
was there a second shooter on the grassy
knoll Naomi Watts reenacts Mulholland
Drive and doesn't even give David Lynch
a royalty check also okay movie fine you
want to blur the line between fantasy
and reality but this kiss comes
completely out of nowhere and serves
these characters in what way again you
mean besides that joint you were smoking
like five minutes ago
was it all dr. drew or anything that
dude from American Pie was there dr.
Drew American Pie did you also hang out
and watch some Buffy while kicking it -
a copy of no scrubs that you downloaded
off Napster also I know Sam doesn't give
it or anything but there are at least
four dudes from American Pie she could
be talking about here I mean she could
say was the dude but or the dude who
drank the couple I mean damn American
Pie was a gross movie wasn't it Sam
didn't even want to do this dare to spit
on a bald dudes head but now that she's
doing it she decides to make it a Flemmi
one also this is the most accurate
spitting I've ever seen and I've been to
all the rodeos that matter if you
weren't afraid what would you want to
get away I'd pull your eyes out of your
head
I'd put them in my own skull look around
so I could see this street the way I
used to when I was your age dude there's
like a million ways you could have
answered that and it wouldn't have
sounded like Ted Bundy in a movie that's
so beautifully plays with the idea of
being one take even as it shifts ahead
in time this night today transition
seems clunky and unnecessary reminder
that we are watching a movie trick and
steals much of the illusion we've been
living in until now what the Lumber
Liquidators ad cuz even pages are always
on the left in my world my massive
hard-on got 50,000 views is nothing to
be proud of but from what I hear it's
not the size of your views it's the
motion of the promotion also luckily
Mike's boner on YouTube happened in 2014
three years before it was inappropriate
for advertisers I mean if Marvel and DC
want me to be excited about this Batman
and honk and vulture crossover fight
while when Stacy and Lego
Kocher look around they're gonna have to
do better than this notice that was 1992
wait so that must have been Batman
I mean Birdman Returns right one hour
till curtain yeah Jake tells Regan
there's one hour till curtain here but
the clock on the wall behind him clearly
indicates it's almost 6:14
that would make the start time of the
play 7:40 which is a pretty damn random
start time if you ask me why is Mike
being so coy about coming through this
door could he really have hurt Leslie
walking by would it have mattered anyway
because that was like Oprah hallmark or
Kelly bad seriously does this movie take
place in 2002 how do you do it Sam
please the pronoun game so the mike has
to ask what the hell it means I guess
the question should ask ourselves is
what do we talk about when we talk about
love roll curtains riggan pulls off his
wig in front of at least half the
audience also did they set up the
backstage area where people on the right
side could just peek while everybody
changes I mean at least block off the
area with the clothes or act or
something geez someone help me with the
geography here the theater he needs to
get back to was on his left yet when he
hits Times Square he keeps walking
straight and then turns right he then
proceeds to walk directly in front of
the band instead of staying out of sight
and then after walking at least three
blocks he then turns to his right and
somehow is now back in front of his own
theater did he fire up his portal gun
when he was out of frame that
distracting moment when you accidentally
walk past two symbols for movie rules
you haven't even done yet
former Batman in a movie about a
Broadway show passes a poster for a
Broadway show based on a movie starring
a former Batman coincidence I think not
how does the ticket lady mount know the
famous movie actor starring in the play
going on in the same building this is my
attorney mr. right apparently these guys
thought the best time to discuss legal
matters was during the performance did
they buy tickets for the stunt or did
security just let them in is this the
first time mr. Roth has tried to call
Jake today do you ever feel like
sometimes art just wants to art so bad
it arts itself till the art drowns in
its own art eNOS just staring down a
dead hole wait for 30 seconds count I
should probably tell you about this for
anybody else does
it's been 5 minutes since we saw him
walking outside in Times Square and
somehow someone found each of these
different videos edited them together
and got them on YouTube and got 350,000
views now wait movie would have taken
longer than that just to upload it even
if they aren't using Comcast other Kurt
stop calling views hits this is not 2003
and this is not a walk
and you don't get to come in here and
pretend you can write direct and act in
your own propaganda piece I understand
the animosity towards critics but the
way Tabitha Dickinson is written makes a
lot of assumptions about criticism that
critics are born to hate on things that
they are failed artists that they go
into every form of entertainment with
the idea of savaging this critic and Bob
Balaban from lady in the water should
get married
barely and they're supposed to only like
things and have no other opinion beyond
that you know less happen in a person's
life anyway despite popular opinion we
have no idea a ranting and raving man
breaks a glass vase in a crowded bar and
no one makes a move to stop him or clean
up around it it's part of the New York
experience coward
riggan Thompson would be amazing at
commenting on cinemasins
oh man we didn't like the Transformers
movies much either but no need to shout
about it on a street corner that's what
YouTube is for can anyone think of a
clever transition to keep our one tape
thing going here
no another time left Skye it is full
shadow of Steel riggan imagines himself
flying around New York City but his
fantasy is such that he imagines the
very real reactions of the people around
him I mean was he ever on top of that
building or has he been in a cab this
whole time imagining it for a movie on
the verge of greatness these are the
small moments that bother me the most
with this cab driver asking to be paid
we are clearly told that him flying
around was a delusion and that he is
mentally ill instead of allowing the
illusion to linger throughout they were
all over me I had a fight my way out of
the water there are only 16 visible cuts
in this movie and all these great
performances how hard was it to make
this thing like the hardest right is it
just me or do they have zero
amplification going on here as quietly
as he's saying these lines could anyone
hear him shouldn't we at least hear some
speaker echo off the back of the
auditorium the crowd applauds the
metaphors complete the artist has
literally killed himself on stage to
please the voices in his head and around
him pan up to the spotlight to finish
off the light motif and the screen goes
black and the movie ends perfectly wait
what is why is the movie still going can
someone tell me why the movie is still
going movie accidentally splices drum
line into itself spider-man turn off the
dark even though spider-man Iron Man
bumblebee and Nick Cannon are all on
this stage and a fantasy sequence it's
still more coherent than most
Transformers movies Thompson has
unwittingly given birth to a new form
which can only be described as super
realism you know what
Tabitha Dickinson really is the critic
this movie has portrayed or asked super
realism is that all she could come up
with and is this really the first time
someone's done something real on stage
also how can the show everyone else
watches after this one would be the same
from this point forward unless riggan
actually shoots himself on stage every
night and survives it um did he I mean
did he how exactly did these three
reporters break through security enough
to get this farm and why didn't the rest
of this scoop hungry press follow the
listing a photo on your Twitter page
this is the kind of nonsense you
butchered the end of another wise great
film for I have never loved a movie as
much for the first 100 minutes and hated
it just as much for the next 10 unlock
DZ open screen 'less windows in the
hospital room of someone recovering from
a possible attempted suicide nope
so does he kill himself thinking it can
fly or not the movie leaves it open for
interpretation like you're in some
imaginary choose-your-own-adventure
movie just to confuse things we have
this shot of Sam going to the window and
smiling which is something riggan could
also be imagining but only if he's not
dead and he's just lying around in bed
right now unless he's dead and god damn
it just tell me if you lived or died
already why don't you get your wings in
your bird suit Oh for some reason I
thought of my first fight with Tyler you
really fucked up this time you sure I'm
not even here maybe just in your head no
way to confirm anything's and I didn't
want to tell you this but martin
scorsees is casting his new film he is
only like a next martin scorsees
can you read my mind he's the guy he's
an Avenger
they put him I hate to hear it Bray's
look the Cape in the boots no capes is
it true you've been injecting yourself
with semen from baby pigs that'll do Pig
that'll do
[Music]
I thought I lost you buddy without
happened are you seriously saying that
there is nothing nothing special about
our relationship